[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qu'il ya qu'est ce qu'il ya
c'est manon et blanc attend mais met à
bas le matin même c'est juste un baiser
passionné et très méchant mais n'est-ce
pas coiffée mais juste la baise et les
politiques
mais est ce qu'on veut mais ça mais je
te prends qu'un incident sometimes bien
sûr aussi vert sencha et je ferai tout
ce que tu veux chanter mais en partant
en vacances en thaïlande
mais s'il vous plaît vous partez en
vacances en thaïlande oui ça va plaire
aux thaïlandaise ça mais moi j'ai qu'une
question c'est est-ce que ça vous plaît
ah ouais et n'oubliez pas que c'est pas
terminé il a fait la base de blond
j'adore la sphère du mèche à mèche ans
il dort sunshine juste après après
l'émission il a peaufiné parce que le
manga johansson c'est moderne et moderne
[Applaudissements]
la trouver
voilà
[Applaudissements]